[Music]
republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green came under fire this week
after a video surfaced of her verbally
harassing representative
alexandria ocasio-cortez's staff back in
2019
before green was in congress accompanied
by a few friends
green yelled at ocasio-cortez's staff
through the mail slot in her office door
and dared the congresswoman to come out
and face her
see for yourself alexandria
ocasio-cortez i'm an american citizen
i pay your salary through the taxes that
you collect from me through the irs you
need to stop being a baby and stop
locking your door and come out and face
the american citizens that you serve
if you want to be a big girl you need to
get rid of your diaper
and come out and be able to talk to the
american citizens instead of just having
to use a flap
guess what you can't stand there forever
can you come out and play
wow that is truly terrifying
hey amber what is that
hey amber ruffin i uh i think it's
coming from the mail slot
amber mildred roofing come on out here
oh my god it's marjorie taylor green
marjorie i am not coming out there
why not because i'm pretty sure you're
gonna try to murder me
i am a peacock subscriber i'll pay your
salary
you pay peacock's monthly subscription
fee well no i have the free version
all right well you need to stop being a
baby
and stop locking your door and come on
out and face your viewers
i don't want to why not i'm worried that
if i go out there things will get crazy
oh baby if i'm here things are already
crazy
come on come on out or let me in
i just want to talk oh yuck i am not
coming out and you sound like a
character from the purge
that's not nice why are you bullying me
you're a bully
i'm not bullying you you're shouting at
me through a mail slot on my door
it's unsettling this is pennywise
behavior
come on you have to talk to me
face to face not through this little
flap no i don't have to talk to anybody
but i'm such a fan oh yeah if you're
such a fan name one sketch on this show
oh well um uh
mean tweets it's not even close look
marjorie it doesn't matter what you say
i'm not coming out there and you are
definitely
not coming in here if you want to be a
big girl
you need to get rid of your diaper come
out from that desk
and talk to me i don't wear a diaper
you wear a diaper help help she's
bullying me
help aren't you a congress person don't
you have a job to do
yes but i i don't understand what it is
no one ever explained it to me okay well
you're a united states congressperson
your job is to represent the
constituents from your district and
to introduce and vote for legislation
that serves their best
interests so no harassing people
no that's not part of your job so
i should probably go get to work yeah
that would be great
okay hi amber
thanks for being such a snowflake
oh no marjorie taylor green everybody
we'll be right back with more of the
amber ruffin show
i'm watching you amber roofing
[Music]
so
you